PlayStation air the brand new streaming
service from the folks at PlayStation
and Gaikai is now available on the
PlayStation 4 allowing you to play video
games via the wonder of internet video
streaming it's about 100 games available
on the surface right now that's costing
$20 a month or $45 per quarter and
currently only available in North
America and I'm here with Peter and
Chris to talk about some of the best
games currently available on that
service first of all what do you guys
think of a price and you many games
available obviously they're going for
like Netflix of gaming 20 bucks no more
of my used to paying for something like
Netflix or Amazon vs video so for
comparison like Gamefly as a rental
service you get discs mailed to you
allah the discs yes what's a disc goes
into the well it's too complicated to
get into now but that's like 16 bucks to
hell one game out of time for a month
and you can up it to 20 a little over 20
bucks for two discs out at a time okay
so the price there it's kind of in the
same ballpark it's a little comparable
obviously that's a whole different
things you have to mail you'll get the
one disc and you mail it back you know
like that's as opposed to just streaming
it so I I don't know it like I
originally was balking at the price yeah
then Peter you had it up and running
today and I had asked you even though I
know what this service I fully know what
the service is about I was like oh did
you get that get streetfighter installed
on PlayStation now yeah it's like no you
don't have to do that you just like you
got and like there it is in your playing
then I don't know if that like actually
hit home to me until you were actually
doing it has the experience work I mean
so keep in mind we're working with a
like super fast like corporate building
downtown San Francisco in that company
bandwidth connection yeah so you know
considering that it works really well
the the video there's a little bit of
compression artifact ting going on where
you know maybe if some mid-tone colors
are going across the screen you'll see a
little bit of blocks here kind of
obscuring a detail colors yeah what's a
mid-tone color a gray cool all right I
dig mid-valley I don't play games with
gray in it
whoops but it's it's also not really
that distracting those those little bits
and pieces and it's something that you'd
expect you know like you mentioned you
don't have to download the game or even
if it's a diss based game you don't do
any sort of installation yeah like some
places PlayStation games required and
you know what the lag was I couldn't
detect any everything yeah I was I
played Final Fantasy 13 Metal Slug and
Super Street Fighter 4 okay
that meant that being a relatively fast
game exactly yeah and I play a lot of
Street Fighter 4 with a pad and doing so
felt the same as it did on a ps3 at
least to me excellent so right off the
additive gate they have a hundred titles
available for you to stream and Peter
what would you say are some of the games
that are a highlight for you on that
service some of the ones I just
mentioned actually uh Final Fantasy 13
is a game I mean to revisit for a while
and like that series really dope off the
deep end but I think the first game did
some things that now I'm more willing to
accept and appreciate and and
considering that it's like a long-form
RPG right yeah you know if you only sign
up for a month that's a game that could
keep you busy for a long time while
you're sampling other things I also
Super Street Fighter 4 as another game
and you can just play endlessly right so
for the the quality of the game and the
time you're allowed to play I really
like those two but then sort of like a
personal favorite is MotorStorm
apocalypse oh yeah it was a racing game
that no one's talked about in a while
but that game had incredible visual
design yes or super fast really fun to
play like that's one of those games is
just sorta like disappears and people
move on yeah but like that's a great
game I love the first motorstorm and I
think that was the sequel that came out
like relatively soon after like 2 year
18 months maybe two years late I don't
member the exact timing yeah but it like
you said it completely passed me by yeah
when you're right if I have access to
that service I well that also raises a
question MotorStorm because you want to
race people right one race people online
in a Playstation now games if you if it
has online multiplayer that's enabled
like oh that's all in there but who's
like is anyone thanks games and I mean
if you go to Killzone 3 and you want to
play competitive multiplayer which is
great how many people are you gonna get
up against you know so it's good point
that's kind of for me when I was
thinking about like what games I would
recommend I was even though I've really
enjoyed the online multi-player and a
lot of those games yeah I can't really
recommend renting them for that reason
so you prefer the single player
experiences available I think the single
player thing is much better and I think
like I was I was parking back to my like
rental heyday I had game 5 for a while
but like my real rental heyday was Sega
Genesis going to the store in my town
before you know when it was the local
store then it was blockbuster I have a
Sega channel I don't know what that is
what
what's AC the PlayStation now for the
Genesis really I kid you not what you
got it through your cable provider Oh in
your system and you could just stream
gasps Oh Rick the knowing was a lag like
Oh God oh gee it was not that no I think
it saved it to local memory so it
actually done oh yeah hey look Lee well
anyway Wow
Sega channel so what games that I got to
get out of my [ __ ] just it yeah when
you're not using Sega channel what game
is on PlayStation so I think one of the
standouts for me personally is enslaved
Odyssey to the West yes because that's
it's a third-person action game use it's
it's two characters a trip and monkey
you play as monkey uses kind of brawler
trip Andy Serkis
yeah he's like this big dude trip is the
sort of brains the operation you sort of
say you save each other from basically
being enslaved and then try to journey
across post-apocalyptic society to get
back to where you're from this is the
kind of game that maybe is a hard sell
for a buy for you because it's like oh
you're gonna be done with it in seven to
ten hours I'm not exactly sure how long
it was but for rent that's a great one
like that's a weekend that's a or a week
with playing a few nights and it's got
so much personality and like the the
environmental design is really slick and
the combat is very cool as well that one
yeah absolutely enslaved and then what
was another one that said when I was
asleep I remember seeing on your list
which made me laugh quite a lot was a
game that's based on any list you can
ever create oh yeah spelunky is lucky of
course the game of the year for all
years that games just fantastic and you
should own it obviously and on
everything on yeah on whatever a game
system you can play it on I mean really
she just buy it on Vita
Veta violent place anyways this is like
a Chris is always talking about spelunky
why don't you shut up about spelunky I
don't want to buy it it doesn't look
that great rent it play it love it
forever buy it be than that by our
slippery platformer and possibly imagine
and then there was a third one who's the
Trib it was bit.trip Thank You Danny
I found this interesting because I
haven't played one or two so this
technically it's bit represents one or
two future Legend of rhythm alien yes I
think is it all right i truncated it
when we put it into the the running
order picture too right big picture
runner to the bit.trip series was super
cool that's a topic for another day but
run or two is you know you're constantly
running and all you're doing is pressing
buttons to slide jump kick and you know
spring in order to get past obstacles
but it's in tune with the music and like
once and like the designs of the level
are trippy it gets exponentially hard it
gets much harder and once you know if it
feels too easy you can rank up the
difficulty really simply there's a bunch
of different characters including a
reverse Merman who's like the head of
the fish and the legs of a dude who has
these huge dangling testicles which are
hilarious
but really it's it this just nails that
euphoric feeling that rhythm games can
have when you when you like your book
your button presses the music the level
design are all in harmony it's an
incredible feeling and this game
captures it better than most awesome
it's interesting we talk about this
because we're bringing up games that we
have basically all played like if I was
to think about one of my favorite games
in the system it would be BioShock
Infinite which is available which
probably one of the bigger like Triple A
games on it
which is one of my favorite games of
2013 yeah one of the best games I've
ever played but we're talking in terms
of these are games we have played these
are on our checklist of games that we
hope others you people should play do
you think that's who's getting this
service or do you think like surely this
is for people who have never played
these games and want to like experience
new games like who do you think
ultimately PlayStation that was for yeah
it's a difficult question because I
think a lot of people don't really want
to go backwards they want to go for
words when it comes to games so I don't
but but you know looking at the the list
of stuff like seeing all that these
games I've played like yeah I kind of
feel like oh I can play it up again on
my playstation before like I always
could have played those games again but
having it right there having it
accessible and literally it's like hit
play twenty seconds later the games
they're like okay I'll play you know I
mean it makes it really easy to revisit
the past I have a feeling that that's
who's this for because I don't know
who's going to pay money to have access
to a buttload of old games especially
ones that old like obviously they're
going to expand this with PlayStation 2
and PlayStation 1 games and do you think
that's going to sort of be more
interesting in terms of like a nostalgic
trip than going back you know five six
years I'm sure then it's Elda did
nostalgia is going to get exponentially
powerful when you go back to ps2 and PS
one of course but it's interesting yet
to think about a library of ps3 games
who does that appeal to does it appeal
to someone who had to played a lot of
ps3 games and wants to go back and play
them I don't think so because I feel
like that person is on to the ps4 does
it appeal to someone who is now getting
a ps3 like I have a friend loves to play
games but doesn't want to get a next-gen
console he's had an Xbox 360 for a
couple years now he's going to get a
PlayStation 3 and play all those
exclusives all that stuff he didn't get
to play and he's super psyched about it
if he could you know when it comes to
PlayStation 3 pay 20 bucks sample a
bunch of those or you know play through
to completion some of them or maybe like
this is a way I was thinking maybe it's
useful as run through in sample which
ones do I want to play more of which
ones do I just want to get a taste of
you know and then kind of be done with
because just getting a taste of stuff is
kind of the core of the rental
experience yes right just giving it a go
and seeing I'm not being scared of
having to throw down 60 and then
actually you know be stuck with a game
rather right and then feel like oh I
have to I have to get my money's worth
of this or I have to take the hit to
resell it or something like that
so I think that could be interesting of
course the like you know am I going to
pay twenty bucks a month so I can like
try out the Last of Us or am I gonna try
to get the Last of Us you know I got a
HD is it better to have it's better for
that reason to have fresher more recent
games but for the nostalgia reason you
got to go to the back catalog and then
they're these games that are in the
weird
between its really strange it's it's a
new frontier for games obviously
something that's happening a lot and
film and music over the past five six
years so it's gonna be very interesting
so if you've any thoughts on what games
you would like to see brought to the
PlayStation air service or games that
are currently on there do you think we
did not mention by all means stick them
in the comments